هذه الطائرات القادمه
وهذه العمليات جاريه حاليا الا ان درجه
اعتماديتها لم تصل الى المستوى الذي يسمح
باستخدامها في المجالات الشائعه ولذلك
اقتصر استخدام الطائره الموجهه ذاتيا على
السيناريوهات الهجوميه في المجال العسكري
وللحملات التجريبيه في الجانب المدني
[موسيقى]
الذكاء الاصطناعي يعامل المساعد على تسريع
التجارب الميدانيه والذكاء الاصطناعي
سيساعد على تقليص مده الاستفاده من
البيانات المتعدده او ما يسمى البيانات
الكبرى ومنحي قدرات استجابه خلال فتره
زمنيه قصيره جدا وهذا يعني ان الذكاء
الاصطناعي سيمنح المنظومه الموجهه ذاتيا
قدره الاستجابه بسرعه البشر او حتى اسرع
من البشر
[موسيقى]
الاول الذي ذكرته يخص الامن السيبراني
وهنا نحن نتحدث عن مكافحه اي تدخلات او
تهديدات خارجيه محتمله تهدف لاختطاف
المنظومه الذاتيه والامن السيبراني ضمن
هذا الاطار يتقدم بسرعه فائقه واستطيع ان
اقول التكنولوجيا متوفره حاليا لهذا الغرض
وحتى في حال اختطاف المنظمات فالتكنولوجيا
متوفره ايضا ضمن السياق العمليات الهجوميه
العسكريه لاحتواء المنظومه الذاتيه حتى
عند فقدان الاشارات من نظام تحديد الموقع
جي بي اس كما ان الناس بشكل عام يعتبرونها
امنه وكما ذكرت خلال كلمه في المؤتمر انا
لا ارى حدودا واسعه بين الاستخدامات
المدنيه والعسكريه
[موسيقى]